and now it's time for bombing reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review Indiana Jones and the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull this is guy
named Indiana Jones who was named after
his dog which is pretty understandable I
had a rat named Wyoming Smith once and
he's abducted by this woman who kind of
looks like a Russian dominatrix now that
I've been to many Russian dominatrix is
only four and he's out to solve the
mystery of the Crystal Skull and he's
always figuring out religious mysteries
in the first one it's Judaism the second
one is Hinduism the third one is
Christianity and in this one is which I
kiss would be Scientology I was almost a
Scientologist once except they said I
was too down to earth for them - Indiana
Jones comes out he's like a bajillion
years old how is it he keeps getting
older don't you remember in the last
movie the Last Crusade or the second to
last crusade think I was like jaded
company will give you eternal life and
the wrong couple is something like from
you I think he took the wrong Cup
because something really sucked the life
out of him I mean that he looked really
bad and the kid for transformers is in
it he's kind of like James Dean except
he has no bones I need it man
no balls there's a scene where he's
fighting with a sword and like a million
things hit his balls no reaction if
something hit my balls I think I have a
reaction I'd be like dude this my balls
a woman from the first movies in it
except she's not like a bajillion years
old she's like half a bazillion years
old and they are out to fight the aliens
what is it with Spielberg in aliens
Close Encounters et War of the Worlds
and now this I think Steven Spielberg is
an alien what human being could possibly
make the lost world and the bad guys are
kind of like Nazi
except the Russian the Russian Nazis I
like to call them
Russia's so Indiana Jones is running
from the rush fees and he gets out his
whip to whip them seriously who carries
around a whip I mean aside for a brush
and dominatrixes and thank you to the
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull where they
come across the alien and the Russian
dominatrix is like tell me all your
secrets and the alien is like me turns
into a giant flying saucer a flying
saucer and in Indiana Jones movie it's
about freakin time the woman is like and
the saucer is like I was like you sure
this isn't the kingdom with the crystal
meth so now I met this is the kind of
stuff I see in Jones is like where did
they go
any other guys like the space between
spaces and I'm like I think you're all a
crystal meth and at the end they play
the famous Indiana Jones song Indiana
Jones year he's been around for like a
million years but the best part of the
movie is when the big rolling ball comes
after him wait no that's not this movie
but he pulls the guy's heart out of his
chest
wait no that's not this one either when
he's fighting on the big tank no no
that's not it either
I don't remember much about this one I
just remember Indiana Jones some Russian
dominatrix and aliens I don't think I
saw the movie I think I must have gotten
high instead I mean who would actually
put all that stuff in the movie so I
guess my advice is watch Indiana Jones
high and you'll get a movie about alien
stops and be on the poster Indiana Jones
he got so high he saw aliens that's
mostly what the Scientologists do anyway
this is history boom scene change
come on Shane come on I'm seeing aliens
in an Indiana Jones movie that can't be
good for me